let's just pick up on what we saw a
little bit in david blevins report of
course counting is is going to resume in
northern ireland in uh an hour or so two
hours time how will a uk government deal
with the fact that shin fein are about
to be the largest party in the northern
ireland assembly
well i think it's important to wait uh
and see the final result uh the the big
uh
focus has to be on
making sure we get the protocol uh to
work i think jeffrey donson was right
on that clip that you just showed
but let's wait and see the final result
of course clearly the
predictions that champaign
has done well
but of course the unionist parties
collectively um
are also
a significant part
of this vote and
the
other parties as well the alliance party
and so on uh the important focus i know
from the secretary of state for northern
ireland is to make sure
that um
the protocol
works um and is fixed um
as soon as possible
because clearly it is an issue uh for
um uh the people of northern ireland and
it's the right thing for us to be
focused on
yeah let's pick up a couple of those
points and uh that protocol sir jeffrey
donaldson says that he basically wants
it just torn up is that something the uk
government would do
well as brandon lewis the
northern ireland secretary said
that you know all options remain on the
table
the important thing is to try and make
sure
we work
with
the
parties in northern ireland but also
with the uh european commission
to make
um you know
to make sure that we leave no stone
unturned
to try and make it work but of course
you know we we need to make sure that
that
all our options are available to us
because ultimately uh the thing to
remember
is uh northern ireland is very much part
of the family that is the united kingdom
i mean just on that then i mean of
course find words uh all options on the
table but you are going to with whatever
decision is made upset someone in this
particular decision be it's the
unionists in ireland or the eu which
ones are you going to upset well i don't
think uh it's a trade-off i think the
important thing is that we
put the people of northern ireland front
and center if that is um
what we do as our priority and we
evidence this then all sides whether
it's the eu
or ourselves should be working towards
making uh the lives of people northern
ireland um
much much better and
for them to see that both the eu
and the uk government are working
together to get the right
outcome ultimately if you if you put
them as
as as the the the people that we want to
make sure we deliver for
all communities then i think it's right
to try and work as hard as we can
to deliver for them and make the
protocol
work
that is our priority that is what the
northern sector will do
but at the same time he will not
compromise on um uh making sure that
that northern is very much part of the
united kingdom yeah i mean you've had
years to do that so you'll forgive
viewers for not being convinced that it
can be done but let's move on to the
local elections
on this island um
the conservative party of lost nearly
500 council seats simple question is
boris johnson still an electoral asset
for the conservatives
so if you look at uh the local elections
and and you have to remember um we are
in mid-term uh coming out of the covered
pandemic into a global battle against
inflation with energy prices now spiking
because of the illegal war in the
ukraine
um take london uh for example of course
i was out campaigning in wandsworth and
um we lost wandsworth and of course
marginally lost westminster as well but
we gained harrow
in london and so it's important that we
listen to our candidates to our
very good counselors of course the ones
that succeeded in the ones that didn't
uh but look at other parts of the
country non-eaton newcastle underlined
first time uh where the conservatives in
25 years now have control of newcastle
underline um
th this has not been a good
night for
sakir stama
in terms of going forward this is a a
result from a local election where we
are in midterm out of a pandemic and of
course
battling a you know this global battle
against inflation and so it's right that
people um
we're concerned there are some local
issues that we have to address as well
as national issues and we'll listen to
those we will not be complacent we'll
listen to to what people are telling us
and we must do better and of course uh
you've got the queen's speech next week
and you'll see um what we're bringing
forward is a plan for jobs a plan for
the economy a plan to deal with the
backlog in the nhs and of course make
sure that national security both abroad
with war in europe and at home are front
and center controlling our borders of
course is very much part of that
national security plan yeah i mean i
didn't hear you say that he was an
assistant let me put it to you here's an
asset absolutely i i know i was really
trying i was trying to give you some of
the evidence uh
of of what i think happened with the
local elections uh but you know you look
at the way boris cuts through in
places like non-eaton places like
newcastle underline other parts of the
country as well harrow in london other
parts of the country
sorry let me just get my next question
because other parts of the country is
exactly right isn't it because the
tories have been wiped out in wales
moved into third place in scotland so
you're happy just being a party for
english people right well
let's take your point about scotland in
2017
scotland we had 115
councillors went up to 275
councils so over doubled so we already
had a very high bar in scotland
now
when you start from such a high bar
you're bound to look at maybe losing
some seats uh there but of course we
we're not going to be complacent we want
to make sure that we deal with some of
the national issues like the global
battle against inflation and of course
the local issues as well but i don't
recognize your characterization that you
know we've been wiped out in scotland
that's not true no no sorry wiped out in
wales because you lost the only council
that you held on with the shows went to
no overall control
and we will try much harder to make sure
that we deal with those issues including
the the investment that's going into
wales of things like nuclear renewables
and of course you know other investments
that we're making uh in wales um this is
the this this is a mid-term local
election that we have to listen to the
voters on and have to continue to
deliver but we have a plan for jobs we
have a plan for the economy a plan to
deal with the nhs backlog and of course
make sure that our borders are secure um
and
deal with war in in europe and all these
things boris johnson is dealing with uh
let me put it to you this way then after
all the issues that have
faced this government and the prime
minister especially being fined and
having to deal with politicians watching
pornography in the house of commons
there were some of your colleagues who
up to these elections were saying that
this will be a moment this will be a
test of the prime minister and whether
we want to go on with him are you happy
that he's passed that test and you're
happy to go on with him are all your
colleagues in agreement with that well
my message to all of my colleagues and i
stood in 1997
in irish
in south london i can tell you that
people don't like to vote for uh split
parties for for teams that are divided
and we are strongest when we are united
we've got a queen speech next week where
we will demonstrate to the nation that
the second half of this uh parliament is
all about dealing with uh repairing the
economy recovering from covert as i've
just talked about the
backlog of the nhs and of course
national security here at home
safer streets and of course abroad
all these things we have a plan for
it's yeah as i say we're stronger when
we are united and that'll be my message
to all my colleagues and you look at
where we are making ground
in in places like the west midlands in
in non-eton and of course newcastle on
the line
people want to see us focus not on um
issues like partygate by the way
sakirshama i think one in three of his
questions at question time were on on
parties yeah and actually neglecting
cost of living uh and of course people
see the hypocrisy of that now you've
seen the headlines this morning
i will i'll put those points to the
labour party when they are not sure i'm
sure you will i'm sure i'm just saying
i'm just reflecting on public opinion
people will will look at that and will
be uncomfortable with the hypocrisy and
the police have now obviously have to
carry out their investigation and let's
see where that ends up yeah absolutely
we will do uh um and then finally there
mrs we you talk about making making
changes um all the indications are that
in the uh um autumn budget there will be
some help for the cousin but people are
really dealing with all of that now why
is the party putting off trying to help
hard-working families who are really
struggling to make ends meet through the
summer just to try and do it in the
autumn well i don't think that's
correct with respect we're not holding
up with the chances of putting 22
billion pounds in the next 12 months
because he recognizes that we're in a
global battle against inflation as is in
america as in the rest of uh europe uh
with high inflation at the moment
spiking because of energy costs 22
billion so let's try and unpack some of
that
you look at the uh taper relief if
people are on universal credit that's an
extra thousand pounds for those people
because of that relief the national
living wage that's another thousand
pounds and then of course the national
insurance
changes he made uh
in terms of the threshold that's another
330 pounds a year for the most
people who are under pressure because of
high energy costs because of high
utility bills and of course we'll
continue to review that continue to look
at that a billion pounds going to local
government who know that who those
people are who are struggling with their
weekly shop who are struggling with
their uh utility bills
all that is 22 billion in 12 months
because the chancellor is well aware of
the pressure that people are under at
the moment because of the spike uh in
energy costs and of course the global
fight against inflation yes it's a hell
of a list of things though isn't it mr
harwin it's very very expensive i mean
reports from the um governor of the bank
of england saying that we're heading
towards recession people's uh bank
balance is really struggling to make
ends meet um where are you on this idea
of a windfall tax on energy firms we saw
shells profits the other day huge
so i think
a couple of things on that one we need
to make sure we get the investment in
our gas assets in the north sea because
clearly
you know that the bosses of these
companies have said they will keep
investing even if they are taxed more
right so so
we need to make sure that investment
happens both
well just just hear me out a second both
shell and bp have announced uh i know
shell 25 billion in renewables bp a
similar number in hydrogen and in
renewables to meet um you know those
those important targets of net zero by
2050 to make sure that we preserve uh
this precious planet and of course
one last thing to remember is both shell
and bp pay double the corporation tax
that other companies pay so corporation
tax for them is about 40 percent uh at
the moment if we want that investment if
we want in in renewables in of course
getting our gas assets so that actually
we don't uh rely on other countries for
the gas that we're going to need anyway
even if you're going to we're going to
move to
a hydrogen economy you still need gas in
that economy those those are the things
that are important and of course the
help that we are putting in 22 billion
over the next 12 months all of that is
the right thing to do when the
pandemic hit both shell and bp lost
billions of pounds that is pensioners
money that is pension funds pensioners
rely on those profits to be able uh uh
to to to make sure that they uh can uh
live well and
pay for the things they need to pay for
so we have to look at this in the round
and be responsible we have a plan for
the economy we have a plan for jobs
labor doesn't